e
we need native code on the
web right now you can write applications
in any language you want as long as it's
JavaScript so this is a funny thing to
complain about as this is
JSC but if you take a look at the larger
Arc right now JavaScript has a very
privileged position on the web
and all other platforms usually have a
way that they can call out to C or C++
or some other
language and this creates a lot of lost
opportunity costs such as integrating
with existing libraries or making it
easy to Port between cell phone
applications and the web and things
along those lines so before we get into
the nitty-gritty of native code it's
worth remembering why we love the web
the web is secure and by secure we mean
that you can point your web browser at
nearly any website run the application
and not worry that it'll upload your
financial information to some arbitrary
website so cat videos no theft that's a
good thing the web is portable you can
view it on any computer any operating
system as long as there's a web browser
you can view it from your cell phone
it's it just runs everywhere there's a
web browser this is great it's ephemeral
so you you don't have to install
anything you just point your web browser
go you don't have to uninstall anything
you don't have to have automatic
computer clean up or anything like that
that's all uh done in the cache and the
web is well not very compatible with
other platforms it's kind of its own
Island so the reason this is is because
of all the things that make the web good
so the web is secure well this doesn't
mean that native applications are
insecure it just means that they have an
entir different definition of what this
means so on the web it assumes your
application is running on behalf of
where you get it from whereas when you
run your native application it assumes
it's running on behalf of you so the
native application can access your
financial information because it's you
and Native applications are typically
compiled down onto the machine so they
aren't they haven't traditionally been
built for portability and you typically
install these so um we'll get to plugins
in a moment but if you have to install
something on the web
you lose 90% of your users 7 90% of your
users right there so if we want native
code to work on the web it has to behave
like the web it has to be secure
portable and
ephemeral we've tried this so everyone
remembers npapi flash Java active x uh
some people even even tried to hack the
browser in order to get this working and
these ultimately these approaches fall
down because it's JavaScript its web
content which calls into native code and
then the native code tries to do its
best job pretending it's just as secure
as JavaScript but ultimately there are
security exploits and you only get
security that's as good as the weakest
link in the chain so gen two is people
finally learn from the pain and said why
don't we try to do things which behave
as if they are web content they're
secure portable ephemeral so there's
portable native client uh which is in
Chrome and allows you to take a portable
uh binary essentially and run it inside
your web browser and then there's M
scripton which compiles native code into
JavaScript and this is one of the main
reasons that this is going to be talked
about at JSC is because it
concerns uh JavaScript and what the
future of JavaScript could be to support
this kind of workflow and a lot of you
have probably heard of asm.js and this
is actually what happens after M
scripton gets a hold of it is it
describes a specific format that m SC
generates so for this talk I will be
talking about M scripton but in your
mind you can while card that to asm.js
if you
wish Pinnacle portable native client uh
works like a traditional compiler is you
take a bunch of C++ source files you
pass it to a slightly modified version
of lovm and it produces a portable
executable this portable executable is a
serialization of lvms internal format
then inside the browser your web page
says Hey I want to embed this portable
executable so Chrome grabs it downloads
it and then looks at it and says hey I
can't actually run portable code you
know my processor isn't portable it's a
real processor so then it goes and
translates it into what the local code
is and it does a few tricks to make sure
we can verify the code is safe so at
runtime you get a setup that's a little
bit like this is that there's a knle
process running these specially
generated machine instructions which is
your native code executing and then when
want is interact when it wants to
interact with the web page it does post
message so JavaScript is sitting there
it can send messages back and forth and
one of the issues is that you don't have
direct access to the Dom so the Dom is
very much single threaded only
accessible by JavaScript and it's very
jealous of this fact so you typically
have to have some glue if you want to
modify the actual web page an
interesting thing is that when you have
a knle process it can only talk to the
browser it cannot talk directly to the
operating system and this means that the
browser notion of security is preserved
so you can't access an arbitrary file on
the disk but you can get any Earl that
JavaScript would be able to get and the
API that this is done with is called
pepper and it's essentially functionally
equivalent with what JavaScript has in
terms of XML HTTP request webgl it's
just a different language binding for
that M scripton on the other hand takes
the approach where it says here's some C
code and I'm going to do some
Transformations on it so it's actually
semantically equivalent JavaScript so
this is an ad function which is prettied
up a little bit to use pointers so we
actually see some memory operations in
the output but it's more or less what
you'd expect if you kind of squint
through all the CR in there there's a
load from memory another load from
memory and then it adds together so
you'll see there's a lot of or zeros in
there and these are bitwise operations
where you're doing a bitwise or with
zero which if you know how or works that
should be a no op you know or with zero
equals what you put in but the trick is
is that JavaScript coerces anything you
or with zero into a 32-bit integer so if
you have a string or if you have a
double it'll mangle it until it looks
like an integer and then you can do
operations on it so this is what aam is
is they've essentially smuggled in type
annotations to The Language by
exploiting the semantics of JavaScript
really weird Corner
cases another thing to pay attention to
is that a memory access where you're
just saying Hey I want this address in
memory is transformed into an indexed
operation an index operation into a type
array so if you're familiar with array
buffers and typed array views that's
what's going on in the bottom is it's
taking a pointer and because the array
view the indexing isn't bite forbite
instead like if it's a 32 integer it's
indexing four bytes at a time you have
to drop the lower two bits of the
address divide it by four so that turns
a pointer address into an array index
interesting consequences of this is that
the address you look up isn't exact the
address you'd normally get in native
code usually it doesn't matter but
there's a few Corner cases where
dropping the lower two bits can bite you
there's also the question of null
pointers so C typically says this the
pointer zero is in some ways equivalent
to null or undefined in JavaScript is it
just means there's nothing there and you
should always check if it's null before
you use it but if you use null in this
case it's like well let me get address
at uh data address zero oh here's the
data at address zero so it doesn't
complain usually with Native code it
will kill the process or something along
those
lines at runtime when you use M scripton
it looks like this is your compiled code
is actually running inside the the very
same thread as the rest of the
JavaScript code and when you want to
call out of the compiled code it's just
calling a JavaScript function so it's a
very quick synchronous Bridge so with a
little bit of wrapping you can get
synchronous access to the Dom and both
the compiled code and the JS code has
access to this big array which it says
is equivalent to the native machine's
memory the consequences of this approach
is that your native code is sharing the
same thread as
JavaScript which means that it has to
obey the same rules as JavaScript it
can't block you have to periodically
relinquish control and there's no other
threads so this means that if you're
porting to use mcrip in you have to
potentially spend a lot of time
refactoring your code so that it behaves
like JavaScript it's asynchronous
callback driven and for some native
applications this is a step too far so a
lot of the stuff we see nowadays that's
being compiled to the web is the stuff
that works easily but there's still a
lot of stuff we haven't been able to do
because of The Blocking and threading
issues this leaves you with a dilemma is
you can go Pinnacle and you say hey it
has threads it's a bit faster it's
closer to what we expect there's fewer
gotas but on the other hand if we go the
MS scripton approach it runs everywhere
JavaScript runs and in many cases it's
easier just to synchronously access the
Dom you don't have asynchronous post
messages so it's a dilemma is we have
two not yet Perfect Solutions and what
can we
do it turns out that these Solutions are
actually closer in many ways than you'd
expect they're both built on top of the
levam tool chain and they both are
trying to produce portable native code
so a lot of the tricks you have to do to
get portable native code working they're
both doing the same thing so I thought
why not create a polyfill that provides
Pinnacles interface to M scripton so if
you're willing to get rid of your
threads and you're willing to make sure
your program's asynchronous then you can
take the same code base and compile it
using both Technologies and I I call
this pepper JS because it's a JS
polyfill of the pepper
interface abstractly that's fairly
straightforward but actually seeing it
in action these are native client
examples SDK examples this is a ray
traced Earth it's doing this all on the
CPU there's no GPU involved and here's
the Pinnacle version of the same thing
uh you don't notice many differences the
one difference of course is that if you
go to the Pinnacle version over here you
can turn on more threads and it's very
hard to see on the VC but you do get a
uh speed up when you're doing that and
uh you know there's other CPU examples
where you can uh just crank on the
thread see it go faster uh exactly the M
same uh code working with M scripton but
there's Corner cases like this is if
your GPU bound it really doesn't matter
how fast you are so exactly the same
application mostly driving the CPU so in
terms of performance is M scripton
actually does very good especially with
numerical kernels so things like Earth
it's usually within One X you know it's
like 20% slower whereas when you have
more structured code you're kind of in
the uh 2 to 3x range in terms of
performance so the performance is mostly
there it's more an issue of developer
time and structure how much time are you
willing to De how much time are you
willing to spend to deth thread your
code well why would you want threads so
I've been pounding on this is that it's
structure is modern developers they want
to Target as many platforms as possible
that you know they want to run on cell
phones they'd like to run on the web but
it's all a return on investment issue is
how much time are you willing to get
that next platform and support that next
platform if that time if that cost is
too much you just don't do it uh there's
throughput we'll see in a a moment that
if you have more threads you can just
crunch more numbers and do more
calculations there's also latency so if
you're doing audio or rendering or Real
Time stuff throughput is kind of the
equation but you want to get it done as
or kind of the question but you want to
get it done as fast as possible so you
never want to have dropouts in your
audio you never want to drop frames in
your real-time application there's also
a trend in Hardware where we're getting
more and more cores and an individual
core can run code about the same speed
as it always has and if you want your
overall application to run faster you
have to take advantage of the parallel
resources in your
Hardware I should uh clarify before I go
on I'm kind of using the uh definition
that the go programming language has uh
done for concurrency and parallelism is
that they're not the same thing so
parallelism is about doing things at the
same time so if you have multiple CPUs
you're running things on multiple CPUs
that's parallelism whereas concurrency
is really about dealing with the
conflicts that arise when you're doing
things that interact so even if you're
running on single CPU you can think in
JavaScript you have problems with
concurrency when you load a bunch of
files and then they may come back not
quite in the order that you expect so
you have to deal with the oh they've
resolved in different orders let me
order them then let me go on on things
along those lines whereas parallelism
you get that when you actually load the
file so while the system is actually
grabbing the btes off the network that's
parallelism but it doesn't interact with
JavaScript until you get the event back
and that's
concurrency so what if we changed how
the browser worked a little bit what
instead What If instead of just running
everything inside the main thread we
spun up a few workers so a web worker is
essentially a thread but you can't
interact with all the other threads the
way you'd want to with native code
because you can only communicate through
messages so what if we just gave it a
big chunk of memory and said this chunk
of memory can be simultaneously read and
written to from all of these different
workers and then you provide some
mechanisms along the lines of locks and
semaphor to make sure that you're never
reading or writing from the same memory
at the same time instead you're passing
ownership uh back and forth between the
threats so this should horrify a few
people in this audience is that shared
memory is known to be hard and a lot of
the design of JavaScript has been shared
nothing instead of uh dealing with all
these concurrency issues the only way
you can communicate back and forth is
over messages so this is the downside of
shared memory is it kind of is going
another Direction it's saying if we
really want native code on the web we
have to deal with the uh issues of
shared memory so people will often say
well there's all these other ways we
could do it and I don't have time to
through these one by one but it always
comes down to there's something missing
and usually what it comes down to is
that whatever solution we do has to be
incremental an incremental evolution of
JavaScript and it also has to require
minimal changes to the native code and
there's very few Solutions which solve
both those for instance you say well why
does JavaScript have to have anything to
do this why are we compiling to
JavaScript why not just use Pinnacle
well that's another technology stack and
getting other browsers to adopt it is
much harder than incrementally evolving
Javas JavaScript so I think in the
future we're going to see a convergence
is that what's happening in mcrip and
what's happening in Pinnacle will uh
start to look uh similar and similar but
we potentially have to evolve JavaScript
to get to that
point so how do we prove that this all
works well um I put together H probably
shouldn't have popped up a uh fluid
simulator and I'm wiggling with my mouse
here and it's tiled and uh everything
like that so what's happening is
underneath all this there is a grid of
velocities and this is a visualization
of the Velocity grid right there and as
you s swirl it around with the mouse the
fluid flows with it and this is a grid
it's a 2 by two grid of image data
essentially and velocity data and every
step it's doing a lot of calculation to
move it forward so this is all CPU
driven this is one of these things that
you think could be very easily
parallelized and so I tried to do it
with the existing workers apis so here's
a version where I'm splitting it up into
multiple workers and one thing we'll get
back to is you'll kind of see although
it's very hard you'll have to squint is
that the velocity buffers when I draw
into it the lines are now kind of uh
lumpy is they aren't as smooth as they
were the first time and we'll get to why
that was but this is running on multiple
workers right now it's in fact running
on four workers and if you look at the
actual uh bottom graph you see virtually
no improvement in fact you'll see a lot
of spikes popping up and those are due
to garbage collection pressure because
you're copying things to the worker
every time well what if you can reduce
the copy so this version says that
instead of copying the same data to all
four workers you copy it once and say
Here's a readon buffer that everyone can
access so it reduces the number of
copies and you'll see that a lot of the
spikes go away so as it turns out the
big win from uh not having to broadcast
the same data to everyone is not
actually the cost of copying the data
it's the copy of cleaning the data up
afterwards so readon memory gives you a
performance boost due to being friendly
for GC what if we go a step further and
say have shared memory and instead of
using post message talk back and forth
we use traditional Native mechanisms
like locks to coordinate between the
threads so at this point we see actually
see our first performance Improvement
and as it turns out this is due to
communication or there is anything else
so when you have a lock that allows you
to communicate with the other threads
much quicker than post message does
we'll get into the actual performance
numbers uh uh when we in a future
slide so this is what's going on behind
the scenes is that uh it's doing a bunch
of computations you don't have to know
exactly what these are but like the a
stages they're just moving things around
uh diffuse velocity that simulates
viscosity and then it has to make sure
that there's no fluid appearing from
nowhere or disappearing so it makes sure
that the pressure is equal at all times
and then it'll
draw how you paralyze this is you take
the computationally Intensive stages and
you move them out to a worker so you're
um doing post message out the worker
says thank you for the data does the
computation sends the results back and
you periodically have to uh
resynchronize back I mentioned that some
of the lines become blotchy and it's
because as soon as you start paralyzing
it there's these gaps that open up on
the main thread and these gaps are
potentially places where things like M
Mouse events can fire so I did a lot of
beautiful abstraction I used promises I
said here are all the things the fluid
simulation is doing and then I changed
the backend implementation detail and
suddenly events started firing in places
I didn't even think about that they'd
fire so this is a concurrency bug is
we're dealing with unexpected events in
places we didn't expect so the great
irony is when dealing with shared memory
my concurrency bug that I ran into was
JavaScript when you actually look at the
speed up um uh shared nothing and read
only memory they give modest
improvements and then we start using
these fast synchronization primes you
can actually start to use all the cores
so on eight cores only 4X speed up so
that's 50% efficiency so it's not quite
where we'd want to be and there's other
things that need to be done but this is
a kind of quick hand waving hack to show
that shared memory does work and it does
give you uh parallel speed up and
performance
Improvement I'm going to skip these
slides for the sake of time but the the
message or the the lesson learned is
that the main thread is actually more
special than you'd expect so the workers
aren't entirely independent with the
main thread and if you block the main
thread you can for instance prevent a
worker from ever creating or from ever
being created so when you initially
create it it creates a stub and it also
launches off an Earl request to get the
script that's supposed to run inside the
stub so if you block the main thread the
script itself is never loaded and the
worker never becomes active and there's
similar issues where if you block the
main thread while a worker is doing
something the console log gets proxied
through the main thread to wherever the
console is and this means you'll lose
output if the main thread is blocked so
for programmers you shouldn't worry
about this but in terms of the browser
implementation it turns out there's all
sorts of complexities where blocking the
main thread will kill you and this is a
problem for running native code because
it's a blocking
API another thing that freaks people out
about native code is data races and this
is a classic textbook I took CS I took
operating systems thing is you say I
have these two threads they each have
two instructions in them and I'm going
to run them at the same time What
Happens so one
thread assigns the value One to a so
assume that A and B are both zero to
start out with so one thread assigns one
to a then prints B the other thread
assigns two to B and then prints a so
what's the end result
if you look at the inner leavings of
these threads you get six possible
results it can print two it can print
one then one it can print one then two
if one of the threads runs much faster
than the other ones you get a zero than
a one or a zero than a two so this isn't
the worst thing in the world is you got
two threads two instructions six
possible in leavings we can deal with
that I I I lied so it's a little worse
than that is that the compiler and the
CPU there's all sorts of things down the
stack which will try to make the code
run faster
and one of the normal things it'll say
is well you're signing to a then you're
printing B these two operations are
totally unrelated so I can reorder them
as I wish and the other thre will say
the same thing is assigning to B than
printing a no relation I can reorder
them so instead you have 24 different
operations and some of them will produce
things which are intuitively silly like
one uh you can print Z Zer which never
should happen because by the time you
hit the other print you would have
thought that the other thread would have
assigned to what you're printing so
there should never be a second zero and
you can sometimes get two zero again
these are physically
unrealizable but it gets worse is for
optimization purposes either the CPU or
the compiler can duplicate instructions
it can remove instructions it can
transform the instructions so instead of
24 inner leavings there's actually
effectively an uncountable number of
inner leavings that can occur with these
threads and even worse is different
threads may not agree on what the inner
leavings are so if the memory operations
aren't dependent they can say hey a got
assign to then B and the other are say
no B got assign to then
a and not every computer will run the
same way so different CPUs will show
some orderings but not all of them and
different compilers will show some
orderings not all of them and this is
especially a problem for JavaScript
because the jit actually behaves as
multiple compilers so as you run it will
recompile the code and potentially
reorder things in different ways every
time it optimizes the code
so this is hopeless right when it comes
down to it if you have a data race your
program is broken so you'll see a lot of
people they'll squint and say okay
there's a data race there but it'll be
okay and the answer is no is that the
compiler of the CPU is going to do the
worst possible thing in some cases and
you can't reason about it so you must
defensively not have data races in your
program well this would be a good
argument against native Cod on the web
right data data races are awful but
really this is about concurrency is
we're talking about doing interacting
things at the same time and if you don't
account for these interactions your
program is broken this also occurs in
JavaScript and I think one of the things
that we'll be learning over the next
five years is that concurrency is a
bigger problem for JavaScript than we
currently understand things like Earl
requests coming back in the order we
didn't expect is we've dealt with
asynchrony with promises but if you have
two promise chains they're interleaving
with each other an odd way
how do you deal with that what
Primitives do you use and right now this
is mostly put upon the programmer to
deal with so this is a wicked problem
but it's a generically wicked
problem and so can we do better is there
a way that we can eliminate data races
and having thought about it for a while
I can say no not really is if you want
to emulate a platform if you want to be
compatible with a platform you also be
have to be compatible with their bugs to
some extent and what this means is that
JavaScript may have to have a shared
memory API for compiled JavaScript which
you probably shouldn't use otherwise and
that scares people so where is this
going is there anything certain and at
this point there is nothing certain
there's going to be a bit of a
discussion slw War for the soul of
JavaScript whether we want to support
native code on the web whether we're
willing to expose shared memory if the
um ultimate uh gain from it is
supporting multi-threaded native code so
you can just Mash together everything
you can Mash C with Javas script it's
not just mashing different web apps
together
anymore I got through that faster than I
expected um but if you want to know more
there's websites for knle M scripton uh
Tri pepper uh js. appspot.com for some
of the examples I was showing uh tweet
at Native client one of my co-workers a
troll he'll enjoy it and uh email me if
you have any uh thing to talk about and
I think we have four minutes and we
might actually be able to take questions
for the first time ever so anyone
curious about anything okay so the
question is are there potential
optimizations where you can just uh copy
stuff into shared memory and pass a
pointer to workers and that's
essentially what the fluid simulator was
doing is that it had this grid of data
and it was saying each of these threads
you're responsible for calculating the
next version of this data for this
specific subsquare so it was it was
essentially handing the pointer off to
the worker and you know kind of of a
region of memory and said process this
and give me the result so for the
non-shared memory version what it was
doing is was actually copying out that
chunk and sending it over and it was a
little worse than that because post
message takes about a
millisecond uh to do a full round trip
you know it has a high throughput but
potentially also a high latency and
because of the high latency when you're
actually doing the fluid simulator like
every update you're having to iterate
about 120 times on a specific
calculation called the Jacobian so if
you do that all over post message then
that means you're taking about 120
milliseconds just for communication
which obviously doesn't work so instead
you have to do things like actually send
it more data than it needs it says
ultimately you're responsible for this
little square but I'm going to give you
data for this much and you're going to
calculate a region that's about twice as
big just so you can predict what your
neighbors are doing and you don't have
to communicate so when you look at those
numbers where you see no speed up what's
actually going on is you're having to do
uh pretty much twice the computation in
all the workers just to avoid
communicating because communicating is
so slow so when you're talking about
avoiding copy by passing pointers to
workers the big win is actually
communication speed is on Modern
processors copying isn't too bad as long
as you don't have to GC afterwards and
if you can avoid it you get an
additional Improvement but the big
Improvement is with synchronization spe
aha so why are we backwards looking why
are we worried about all this Legacy
code well this is often brought up in
these wars about should we have shared
memory or not and my my answer to that
is
that people are still writing new native
code every day you know everyone talks
about Native on mobile so if we're
talking about compatibility with native
code we're really talking about can
mobile developers easily p back and
forth to the web you know can we make
the web as a last Bastion of not being a
Walled Garden you know if you want to be
really political about it or something
like that so it's about compatibility
with different platforms more anything
else and people are saying well why
don't we provide an isolates API you
know why don't we say that native code
just gets web workers and you have to
send messages between the different
threads of native
code and how are you going to get people
to do that you know that's a huge change
so you're still asking for award world
where people have to design for the web
first is they have to say well I am
taking on these constraints where
everything goes in web workers and I'm
not using any Library which happens to
use a thread so there's a fairly
hilarious um discussion I saw on the
mcrip and IRC where someone's like I
can't compile this Library it's saying
not finding wind threads. or something
along those lines and then the person is
like well you can't have threads and
they're like I don't care if I have
threads I just want the library to work
so there there is certain Mas ability
things is you just want to put the
libraries together and have it work and
not worry about the underlying things so
requiring a massive rewrite of
everything that's a bit of a
non-starter thanks thanks
Nick